what do you think can we only learn
through direct experience or also from
studying others
psychologist albert bandura came up with
an interesting experiment to answer that
exact question and form a theory
bandura came up with a social learning
theory in the 1960s a time dominated by
scholars who didn't believe bandura's
idea and argued that learning was always
the result of classical and operational
conditioning to prove that children can
learn by mere observation bandura came
up with the bobo doll experiments a set
of controversial studies which involved
preschool children adult models and a
stand-up punch doll
in the first set of experiments the
children were seated alone in the corner
of the room from there they observed an
adult actor aggressively kicking and
scolding the bobo doll for about 10
minutes
afterwards the same child was put into a
new playroom where another adult
deliberately frustrated the child by
taking away the toys a child played with
the frustrated child was then put back
into the room with a bobo doll where
bandura and his team made the following
three observations 1. children who
initially saw the adult punching the
doll often copied the behavior 2. boys
were 3 times more likely to do so 3.
boys reproduce the behavior twice as
often if they observed a man do it
compared to boys who observed a female
actor girls were also more influenced by
same-sex models
to find out if movies would have the
same effect bandura let some children
watch the model live and others watch it
on video or as a cartoon animation as
all three groups showed similar
responses bandura concluded that
children imitate others regardless of
where they have seen the behavior
in the last variation of the experiments
bandura wanted to know if the children
would act differently when the models
were reinforced or punished for their
behavior towards the doll now the
children first saw the actor hit the
doll and then observed another adult
enter the room this second adult would
then react to the actor
[Music]
these last results show that it did not
make much of a difference to the
children whether the aggressor was
praised or not however the kids who saw
that the model was punished displayed
much less aggression later an effect
which was especially true for girls in
other words seeing others being rewarded
does not necessarily motivate us to copy
their behavior seeing others being
punished on the other hand can
significantly diminish our will to copy
it
the fact that bandura was able to prove
that children also learn by observing
others was a breakthrough in psychology
as a consequence of his findings
scholars and government officials argued
that we should ban violence in films and
games others suggested that the bobo
doll studies are not studies of
aggression but rather show that the
children are simply motivated by the
desire to please adults or act like them
bandura and his co-author richard
walters later defined five key tenets of
the social learning theory one learning
is a cognitive process that takes place
in a social setting two learning can
occur by observing behavior and the
consequences of such three learning can
happen without an observable change in
behavior because we may learn without
displaying what we have learned four
reinforcements play a role but are not
entirely responsible for learning 5.
cognition behavior and environment all
mutually influence each other a process
called reciprocal determinisms
[Music]
bandura who in college attended a
psychology course only to kill time soon
became passionate about the topic and
then one of the most cited psychologists
in history
[Music]
about reality he said most of the images
of reality on which we base our actions
are really based on vicarious experience
what do you think how much of your
learning comes from observing others and
if you learn socially who are your
greatest teachers
[Music]
this and all other sprouts videos are
licensed under creative commons that
means teachers from all around the world
can use them in classrooms online
courses or to start projects and today
thousands already do to learn how it
works and download this video without
ads or background music check out our
website or read the description below
if you want to support our mission and
help change education visit our patreon
that's patreon.com
sprouts